This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Canon PIXMA Pro inkjet printers: Exactly as
you envisioned.
It’s a debate that’s been raging on since
the dawn of photography: The rule of Thirds,
vs. the Golden Ratio.
So what are they, and is one REALLY better
than the other?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and those
of you who enjoy photography have probably
heard of the Rule of Thirds.
It’s a general rule of composition for both
photos and film, and it’s the reason almost
all cameras come with those gridlines that
divide the photo into 9 equal sections.
The basic formula is that the object you’re
trying to highlight or bring attention to
in your photos, should be positioned either
along on a gridline or at an intersection
of two lines.
The idea being that it creates more tension
and interest, than simply centering the object.
For hundreds of years, the Rule of Thirds
has been one of the most universally accepted
guidelines for composing photographs.
But recently, many have chosen to eschew it
in favor of the Golden Ratio.
So what is the Golden Ratio, and how does
it apply to photography?
Well, much like Pi, the Golden Ratio is an
irrational number, roughly approximated to
1.618.
And that number is based on a very specific
formula.
Suppose you have a finite line A, and somewhere
in the middle of that line is a point, separating
it into two segments of different lengths.
We’ll call the longer line B and the shorter
line C.
Now, if you were divide the length of B by
C, and it was EQUAL to the length of A over
B, then those two numbers would be in the
golden ratio.
And from there, you can create something called
a Golden Spiral.
It’s a logarithmic spiral - which are found
all over the place in nature - but with a
growth factor that’s equal to the golden
ratio.
Meaning that for every quarter-turn the spiral
makes, the line gets 1 Golden Ratio further
away from its center point.
Eventually creating something that looks like
this.
And it’s this spiral, that’s the basis
for the Golden Ratio rule of photography.
The idea is that by overlaying the Golden
Spiral on top of your photographs, you want
the focal object to line up at the intersection
of those two red lines.
So if you were taking a portrait, for example,
you’d want the person’s eyes to be right
around that point.
You can also expand those red lines along
the length of the image, and mirror them on
the other side, ultimately creating something
called a Phi grid - Phi being the symbol for
the Golden Ratio.
So when people talk about using the Golden
Ratio to compose their photos, what they’re
really talking about, is using a Phi Grid
- instead of the grid used for the Rule of
Thirds.
As far as grids go, they look relatively similar.
But a lot of people claim that the Phi grid
is a better choice, because it produces a
more balanced image - especially when it comes
to landscape photography.
The main complaint with the Rule of Thirds
is that it can look too obvious - whereas
the Phi grid, makes photos appear more natural
and less rigid.
For now, it seems like both options are still
valid rules of photography.
But the Golden Ratio is definitely the better
choice for certain scenarios, like landscapes,
and in general - it’s just a little more
pleasing to the eye.
Since we’re talking about aesthetics, now’s
a good time to thank our sponsor.
With PIXMA Pro Professional inkjet printers,
you can expect a level of quality and accuracy
that keeps each print true to your unique
vision.
All backed by Canon's commitment to provide
professionals with fast, high quality service
you can depend on.
Would you guys agree with that statement?
And what rules of thumb do YOU use when taking
photos?
You can let us know your thoughts in the comments
below - otherwise, thanks for watching!